[Music]
joe biden's handlers have claimed again
and again that he will stick with the
schedule set by the commission on
presidential debates
and face off against the incumbent three
times before the election starting next
month and they've claimed that as
recently as today
of course that promise is being taken as
a threat
by democratic operatives around biden
they know that their candidate's poll
numbers depend entirely on voters being
unable to
see or hear him speak if biden is
allowed to talk in public he will ruin
everything that's why this summer the
new york times ran a piece by tom
friedman saying that biden shouldn't
debate unless
trump releases his tax returns it was an
obvious ploy we noted that at the time
but at least
tom friedman tried to pretend he was
taking a principled stand it was about
fairness he claimed
it had nothing to do with joe biden's
inability to think
clearly just fairness but leave it to
former bill clinton press secretary joe
lockhart the dumbest person ever to hold
that job
to shatter the facade in a column last
week conspicuously titled joe biden
could still lose this election joe
lockhart spelled out his prescription
directly to biden
he used words even biden could
understand dr seuss level stuff
whatever you do lockhart wrote to joe
biden don't debate
trump end quote got that as if he needed
to spell out his contempt for voters a
little more clearly
lockhart warned that trump quote can't
follow the rules
or the truth that's coming from the
flack for the president who was
impeached for lying
it's coming from the man who posted a
made up conversation between republican
senators back in january
irony of course is dead the pallbearer
is joe lockhart but lockhart is hardly
alone
strategists and operatives have received
their marching orders
bill crystal the fervent democratic
partisan today
tweeted that joe biden shouldn't debate
the public shouldn't know any more than
it already does
too much information could be bad for
our plans to take power
shut it down tells you everything
well speaking of the ability to freely
disseminate information
77 percent of republicans polled said
they were afraid to express their
opinions publicly
they know that expressing
right-of-center views could get them
fired
so what is the conservative
establishment the groups that take in
billions every year to protect
conservatives doing to protect
conservatives